We are taking phone calls at (617) 830-4750.
I want to go next to Aaron from New Jersey
who last time he called, described himself
as a die hard Biden fan.
This is someone I definitely want to talk
to.
Uh, Aaron from New Jersey.
What's going on?
Are you still a die hard Biden fan?
Hi David.
Thanks for taking my call.
Yes, I am actually wow.
As a black man.
Um, I kinda feel like that's my only option,
really the only viable option for someone
like me.
Okay.
Let's explore.
Hold on Aaron.
Let's not, you're saying things that we wanna
explore.
What policy of Biden's makes it so obvious
to you as a black man that he is the candidate
for you and no one else could be?
I'm not saying that as policy based, but,
um, I think that, um, like we have a certain
amount of respect for Barack Obama that we
like what would he want?
I think that respect in his legacy.
I think that, um, Biden would be the appropriate
candidate for that.
What evidence do you have that Obama thinks
that black people would be best off voting
for Biden?
I think that just the connection that they
have, they're kind of synonymous with each
other.
No, I know, maybe not everyone sees that in
terms of policy, but I know that when I think
of Biden I think of, Oh, I'm Obama [inaudible].
Okay.
All right.
So I'm hearing you Aaron say that it's Biden's
association with Obama that makes him the
only choice for you.
I know you said it's not necessarily about
policy.
Is there any policy you can point to of Joe
Biden's that makes you believe he will be
the best candidate for black Americans?
No, but I think I do know what, um, appeals
to us.
Well, you told me that you, that you told
me.
Well, I mean from a policy perspective, which
was that you're asking me about and that is
that, you know, what we have right now and
where I think Bernie and Elizabeth Warren
would do is they would go to the extreme,
but you know, from these past two, two and
a half years or so, I just want to get my
main man Joseph in there so I don't have to
think about politics anymore.
You know, I know he's not gonna rock the boat.
I don't want to have to think about politics
or,
got it.
So Aaron, if I may, if I may, Erin, what policy,
you mentioned that Bernie, you know, Bernie
Warren extreme, what would be an example of
an extreme policy that as a black American
you'd be worried about from Bernie or Warren?
Well, she can help healthcare.
I don't want to have to think about that.
Yo, uh, me, what we have now is an ideal,
but like I don't want to have to worry about
like things that I asked to get involved in
or things that are actually going to affect
me in a way that, you know, everything right
now.
It works pretty well.
Right?
So hold on.
If, if, so if someone came forward and said,
Hey, so what, did you have insurance through
an employer now?
Or what's your insurance situation?
Well, right now I'm still on my parent's insurance
up.
I'm 26.
I'm, I'm, I'm gonna have to get my own pretty
soon.
I'm 25 actually.
So you know, I don't know if you know this,
but when you, when you in a couple of years
you will have to either buy insurance, which
could cost, you know, many hundreds of dollars
per month or you will have to get a job.
And when you get that job, they will give
you options and you will be able to say, okay,
I get to pay one third of the total and they
will pay two thirds if they're extremely generous.
Um, what does the plan cover?
But what is the deductible?
Doesn't it sounds simpler to just be able
to say, Oh, I'm now 26 I'm off my parents
insurance now I just got Medicare for all.
Doesn't that sound simpler?
Possibly.
But I think it's a harder sell
to who,
because like I think to the general American
who's not really in the weeds on politics.
Okay, so that's maybe a messaging issue.
That's maybe a messaging issue, but you can,
it sounds like you're agreeing that rather
than having to say, what's my maximum out
of pocket with this plan and can I afford
the one 80 a month?
That would be my contribution.
Just having Medicare for all.
When you turn 26, you agree, it's simpler.
You're saying though that it's maybe not been
messaged correctly.
Yeah, that could be the case.
Yeah.
All right Aaron.
Very good.
Okay.
We shoot the phone call.
I, I am, um, you know, a little bit concerned
about what you're telling me.
I'm not gonna lie, but I do appreciate you
talking to me.
Oh, thanks.
No problem.
Thanks for taking my call.
Very good.
All right, we'll talk to you soon.